[Music]
hey everyone
whilst we normally cover heavy spoilers
on the heavy spoilers show which is why
it's called well the heavy spoilers show
I thought I'd drop a quick no spoilers
review on the new dark crystals age of
resistance series that's just dropped on
Netflix this is more sort of a general
discussion of the entire season and if
you're looking to hear whether it's good
or bad I have to say that from the off
it's a great start of the series that
really feels like a piece of art
throughout its 10 episode run I will be
covering the show in more depth down the
line but I think this just kind of
deserves some coverage - the spoilers
because of how breathtaking it is now
those who were around for the original
movie will know that whilst it was a
pretty great ride and never quite got
the critical acclaim it deserved and
even today it almost has a cult
following so when I heard that Netflix
were using some serious money to bring
the story up to date it seemed like an
awesome way to garner interest once more
in the entire thing from the off the
series can be a bit overwhelming with
the amount of tribes species and people
that the show dumps on you from the
introduction but it's definitely worth
sticking with and once you get your head
around the law and characters of The
Dark Crystal the show is really easy to
get behind now whilst the characters may
catch you off guard in the beginning
what wound and is the big thing that
will hook you in in my opinion is the
way that the show uses puppets and
animation to paint out its picturesque
landscape that feels like something
ripped straight out of your childhood
everything looks and feels immaculate
here and it's easy to forget that these
on real living things and that you're
actually watching some of the best
animation ever put to screen the biggest
problem with the original film was that
the puppets didn't really age well
however Netflix completely corrects this
due to the increased budget and
technology of modern day and it makes
for a seamless show that's incredible to
watch the show itself is set in a land
of draw and contains a classic
between light and dark with the
golfing's taken the main stage as the
protagonists they're amazingly designed
it and have an almost early disney-esque
look to their faces that certainly gets
you onboard of them you might need a map
in front of you at the start whilst
watching it
but there's nothing here that fans of
Game of Thrones won't be able to
overcome within a couple minutes of
watching what the show beautifully does
is that it balances all of its
complexities and paints it in a way that
is rather simple once you're on board I
find most Netflix shows just become
background noise after a while and easy
watching that doesn't really require
much concentration and whilst the Dark
Crystal is more than capable of doing
that if you don't wish to engage with it
fully it's also possible to become fully
swept up in its law this is a sort of
prequel to the original film so you
don't even need to have seen that in
order to enjoy this new project whether
they will eventually delve into the
events of the movie remains to be seen
but they're more than capable of doing
that or going off in their own direction
if they choose to add to this the
awesome cast made up of the likes of
Mark Hamill Simon Pegg Andy Samberg and
more and you have some awesome voice
actors that really bring the puppets to
life overall the Dark Crystal is an
awesome first season that whilst not
perfect definitely does its job of
reintroducing the Dark Crystal franchise
to the world this is a perfect example
of how Netflix can resurrect
long-forgotten franchises and bring them
fully up to speed for new audiences
whilst also remaining faithful to
previous iterations without damaging the
love that older fans have for the work
it's a blast and whilst I think it may
weigh in a little long at 10 hours this
is a brilliant beginning to a franchise
that will clearly go on to bigger and
better in the end the Dark Crystal is
great and that's why it gets an 8.5 out
of 10
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the show and if you enjoyed it or not
drop your review in the comments and
make sure you check out my breakdown of
this weekend's other big release the
spider-man far from home extended Kirk
what you'll be linked at the end I go
over all of the added scenes and
everything that you need to know about
them so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more if you want
to come talk to me about movies TV shows
games and comic books and you can follow
me on twitter at definition whitey it's
the best way to get in touch with me and
the perfect places yet new videos and
content so hopefully I see you over
there after this I also just wanna let
you know that we're giving away a free
copy of John wick three and blu-ray and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
Dark Crystal in the comments section
below the winner will be chosen at
random on September the 10th and the
blue will be shipped out from them to
ever get surprised it's the best of luck
to everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]